والاقتصاد كلمه السر التي اوصلت العداله
والتنميه للسلطه في نوفمبر 2002 على اثري
ازمه اقتصاديه حاده التخلص منها ابقى
الحزب في السلطه ل 20 عاما واليوم تحولت
نعمه الاقتصاد في تركيا الى نقمه
تهدد عرشه في السلطه بعد ما اوصلته اليه
في 2010 تعاهد اردوغان بزياده الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي الى تريليونين دولار
الوصول لقائمه ال 10 الكبار اقتصاديا
بحلول 2023 اي بعد ايام لكن المؤشرات على
الاخفاق بدات منذ عشر سنوات
بينها عمي 2013 و20121 انخفض الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي من 957 مليار دولار الى
و15 مليارا وتراجعت
هي في قائمه الاقتصادات العالميه الاكبر
من المركز السادس عشر الى التاسعه عشر
حاول اردوغان حلى بعضهم معدلات الاقتصاد
بتشجيع الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وتقديم
الجنسيه التركيه للمستثمرين في العقارات
في مبلغ لا يقل عن 40000 دولار سلاح ذو
حدين ساهم في ضبط تدفق العملات الاجنبيه
لكنه اشعل اسعار السلع الاساسيه بالنسبه
للعديد من الاتراك ومن بينها الخبز لكنها
فئه من الاتراك حصنها اردوغان انتخابيا ضد
تداعيات الازمه الاقتصاديه دائره
المستفيدين من الدعم المالي الحكوميه
عندما وصل الحزب الى السلطه عام 2002 كان
عدد المتلقين للمعونات الحكوميه حوالي
0.38% من الشعب التركي اليوم تخطط النسبه
حاجز الواحد فاصله 37% كما ي لا مئات
والالاف من موظفي الدوله التركيه للولاء
الى اردوغان وحزبه الذين حارثوا على
تعيينه وترقيه انصار الحزب يخشى هؤلاء
سيناريو ياتي بحكومه جديده تغير الكادر
الحكومي وتاتي باتباعها